All right, so we've been talking about security architecture and engineering and just to
refocus. That means how we. All right, so we've been talking about security
architecture and engineering and just to refocus. That means how we build
architectures but also protect them by going through the engineering process
itself which are the phases of how we need to involve security right from the
start and throughout each of the phases. Now what can be really helpful from a
security perspective is what we call models. Now before we get into what we
call security models, we have to pause here and think about what the word
model actually means because these are really useful in security. The word
model is simply a representation of something. So if we have something that
represents what the ultimate architecture needs to look like, it can be
really helpful from a security perspective. So security models provide the
rules by which we can build something that ultimately is going to be secure. So
there are security models that exist out there that have been around for a
very long time that can provide the rules by which we can implement security
and ultimately have secure architectures that become importantly secured from
a confidentiality perspective, from a integrity perspective. We typically don't
need models to tell us how to achieve availability because availability is
addressed through redundancy. We don't need rules to be able to understand what
that is like. We simply build in cost-effective redundancy and we achieve
availability. But there are rules by which we can achieve confidentiality and
integrity. Those are referred to as security models. And some of these I'm sure
you've heard of, Bellapagela, Biba, Clark Wilson, Brewer Nash are the major
models that we need to focus on as far as the exam is concerned. Now what you
need to remember is that there are really two types of models that only exist.
Latest-based and rule-based. Only two types of models. Latest-based and rule-based.
There are only two Latest-based models that we need to concern ourselves with.
And the difference between them will be very apparent for you. But basically one
addresses confidentiality only. The other one addresses integrity only. That's the
difference between the two Latest-based models. So if you see questions on the
exam that talk about what is the Latest-based model, then you know that the
answer can only be one of two choices. Bellapagela only addresses confidentiality
and Biba only addresses integrity. So first of all, let's look at what a
Latest is. So if I say the word Latest, what comes to your mind? You may
picture something that you see on your screen here as the slide. The best way to
think of what a Latest-based model is is a layer-based model. So we've got
different layers that provide different levels of security. So let's start, for
example, with the first one, which is Bellapagela. The names of these models
come from the people that came up with the rules in the first place. And this
model actually dates back to the early 70s. But it was Bell and La Padilla that
came up with the rules that we have to implement in order to address confidentiality.
Now a lot of people think, why is it that we have to still think about these
models, you know, decades later. Surely they've become obsolete. But the answer
to that is something that all of us as security professionals should
understand. And that is even though these models are very old, the fundamental
concepts that they address and therefore the rules to achieve, for example,
confidentiality are the same today as they were decades ago. And they will be
the same decades from now. The fundamental rules and concepts are the same in
how we dress confidentiality. Technology has changed, but the fundamental rules
will never change. And so it's important for us to realize what those rules are
that you need to implement in order to achieve confidentiality. So these two
people thought, okay, if we want confidentiality to exist in any environment,
what are the rules that need to exist? What are the rules that we need to enforce?
And the first thing that they thought of is, okay, what happens in any architecture?
There is always interaction between two entities. Those two entities are subjects
and objects. I mean, when you look at any architecture, those are the two
fundamental entities that will always interface with each other. And the
difference between them, as we've learned before, is that subjects are always the
active entity. The objects are going to be the passive entity. But if we want
security to exist, we have to enforce rules between subjects and objects. So if you
think of a lattice-based model, which is a layer-based model, this model only
addresses confidentiality. So let's use a example. Let's say that we have three
levels of confidentiality, high, medium, and low. And we have subjects, we have
been placed in the medium layer. From a read perspective, what is it that
subject should be able to do from a read perspective? So if we are in the
medium layer, what can we read to enforce confidentiality and always have
confidentiality requirements be addressed? Well, we can read anything that's in our
layer. You can always do anything in our layer because that's the layer that
we've been placed at. But we can also read anything that is below us. Because
anything that is below us is less sensitive from a confidentiality perspective. So
if you allow reading down, you are not breaking confidentiality requirements.
However, we should not allow reading up because if we do, then you'd be
allowing subjects to read sensitive information that they are not cleared for.
That would break confidentiality. So the first rule of Bellapagela is actually
if you have read capabilities, you can only read at your layer or down. Now
what if we have right capabilities, right capabilities? Let's say we're in
that medium layer. And so what is it that you can write to? Well, if you think
about this from a confidentiality perspective, you can always do things that
your own layer. So we can write to objects at our own layer, but to enforce
confidentiality, what do we need to do? We need to allow either writing up or
writing down to enforce confidentiality. However, you would allow writing up and
not down. And here's why. If you allow writing down, we'd be taking knowledge
that is available to us at the medium layer. And we'd be writing it down to a
lower layer thereby disclosing confidential information to those people that are
below us. That would break confidentiality. And therefore, writing down is not
allowed. Writing up, however, is okay from a confidentiality perspective.
Because those people above us can already read what exists in our own layer. So
it's okay to take anything from our layer and write it up. That does not break
confidentiality. So that's the second rule of the Bellapagela model. You can read
at your layer or up, not down because that would break confidentiality. Now, the
only last rule that exists here with Bellapagela is really combining both
rules together. What if you have the ability to read and write? Well, based on the
previous two rules, the only thing that you can do is read and write at your own
layer. Nothing higher, nothing lower. And that's what we depict here as the last
rule in the Bellapagela model. Now, one more thing to think about here before we move
on to the next lattice-based model. But these guys, Bell and LaPagela, actually
named each of these rules. The ability to be able to read is referred to as the
simple security property. So if you see simple on the exam, it simply means the
ability to read. The ability to write is referred to as the star property. So if you
see star, it means the ability to write. And of course, we know that you can only
write at your layer or higher. And the ability to read and write is referred to as the
strong star property. So strong star means being able to read and write at the same
time. Now, let's move on to the next lattice-based model, which of course is called Beba. Remember
Bellapagela only addresses confidentiality. Beba only addresses integrity. All right, now
the Beba model is something that only addresses integrity. This guy called Beba came along
years after Bellapagela. Looked at the Bellapagela model and said, wow, this is a great model,
but in my environment, Beba said, I'm only interested in integrity, not so much confidentiality.
I'd like to have a model that is similar, but addresses integrity, not so much confidentiality.
And so basically what he did is he took the Bellapagela model and adapted it to address
integrity. Maybe he worked in a bank where something like integrity is very important.
So what he did is he modified the rules to address integrity. Before we can understand
this one, we have to just pause for a second and think about what integrity actually means
from a security perspective. I think we've talked about this a few times, but integrity
means meaningfulness, timeliness, currency, but accuracy is something that integrity really
addresses. And if we think of integrity as addressing accuracy, it allows us to understand
this model really easily. So instead of having three layers, let's say, of confidentiality,
like Bellapagela addresses, this one addresses layers of integrity accuracy. So let's say we have
three layers of accuracy, high, medium, and low. And just like before, we've been placed in
the medium layer. Now, from a read perspective, what should we be able to read? Well, if you think
about this, because we are reading layers of accuracy, it's going to be the opposite of Bellapagela.
We should not be able to read anything that is lower than us. Because if you allow that,
you are allowing people to read information that is less accurate. And so what you want is you
want people to be able to read levels of higher accuracy, because reading higher accuracy information
allows us to become more accurate, more knowledgeable, more current, more accurate in our knowledge.
So in this case, we allow reading up, not down, because if you allow reading down, you'd be allowing
people to read less accurate information. But if they can read up, they can read more accurate
information, which obviously allows them to be more accurate in the decisions that they actually
make. So the Bibel model is actually the opposite of Bellapagela. We do allow reading up and not
down. And similarly, if you have right capabilities, what should you be able to write to? Well, you can
write to your own layer, because you can always do things at your own layer. But in this case,
we allow writing down, because you're taking information from our layer, which is more accurate
than the layer below us. So by taking knowledge of information from our layer and writing it down
to a lower layer, you are improving that layer with more accurate information, which is a goal of
accuracy and integrity. So again, this is the opposite. We allow writing down, we should not allow
writing up, because again, that layer is already more accurate. If we allowed writing up, you'd be
contaminating that layer with less accurate information. So the second rule of Biba is you can write
down, not up. And then the third rule is combining these together, right? That's called the strong
star property as well, which means you can only do things at your own layer, nothing higher, nothing
lower. Now, there is a third rule or a fourth rule, basically, that is called the invocation
property. Invocation properly simply means that you cannot send information to someone that is
rated at a higher layer of integrity than you are, because again, you'd be contaminating their
knowledge with less accurate information. So it's almost like the ability to write rule that we
just described. Now, what you need to remember about the Biba model as well is that he kept the same
names that Belapagela came up with. In other words, simple star and strong star, but the difference
here is the second word. This is going to help you on the exam. If you look for the second word
after the words simple star and strong star, it's going to tell you whether the exam is talking about
the Belapagela model or the Biba model. Because if the second word says integrity, for example,
simple integrity property or the star integrity property or the strong star integrity property,
then obviously they're talking about the Biba model. If it says anything else like the simple
security property, then they're talking about the Belapagela model. That's how you distinguish
between the two. So that essentially is the Biba model. Now, what if you're an organization
where confidentiality and integrity are requirements like most organizations today? So you may want to
implement both Belapagela and Biba. But if you look at the rules that they each enforce,
you see that they're the opposite of each other. So if you implement both Belapagela and Biba,
you'd have models that really cancel each other out, which would mean that nobody would have
access to anything, which I suppose would be very secure, but not very practical. And so how do you
implement both Belapagela and Biba together? Which obviously are requirements of most organizations
today. Well, the way that you do it is called the Lippner implementation, named after this guy
called Lippner, who was able to take both Belapagela and Biba and put them together. And it's not
really considered to be a model on its own. The Lippner is referred to as a implementation
and not a model, but he was able to take both Belapagela and Biba and put them together and
actually make them work in an organization. It's called the Lippner implementation of both
Belapagela and Biba.